we're beginning with some new
developments in the controversy over
misinformation about covet on spotify
specifically on joe rogan's popular
podcast so it all began when rock legend
neil young asked spotify to either
remove his music or the podcast that joe
rogan experience young and others say
episodes of rogan's show promote false
information about kova 19 and the
vaccines spotify honored young's request
and removed his music the streaming
service said yesterday that it's working
to add content advisories before any
podcast episode that discusses the virus
rogan said last night that he agrees
with those advires advisories rather but
also defended his program
my
point of doing this is always just to
create interesting conversations and
ones that i hope people enjoy so joe
rogan struck an apologetic but defensive
tone late sunday night responding to
accusations that he is responsible for
spreading false statements on his show
the joe rogan experience i'm not trying
to promote
misinformation i'm not trying to be
controversial
but his show a spotify exclusive and the
number one podcast on the platform has
spread misinformation including claims
that the drug ivermectin is an effective
treatment for covid and that microchips
are in vaccines last month he spoke with
two doctors known for promoting vaccine
falsehoods they have an opinion that's
different from the mainstream narrative
i wanted to hear what their opinion is
these doctors and nurses are on the
front lines they're dying you don't turn
your back on them for power or money you
stand with that nils lofgren the
guitarist in bruce springsteen's e
street band and who also tours with neil
young joined him
and joni mitchell by removing his music
from spotify over misinformation on
rogan's show spotify ceo daniel x said
in a blog post sunday that the company
has a critical role to play in
supporting creator expression while
balancing it with the safety of our
users adding it's important that spotify
doesn't take on the position of being
content censor
it's not about any censorship we're all
for free speech we just don't want to be
associated with
misinformation and lies that are killing
americans coven misinformation has been
a battle for tech companies for the past
two years as facebook twitter and tick
tock have all faced criticism for
handling users posts bloomberg media and
entertainment reporter luca shaw said
spotify has largely escaped this debate
until now spotify took a big step today
in acknowledging that it needed to do
something and it needed to more
aggressively police misinformation
but believes that sort of a less is more
approach when it comes to content
moderation
so let me just share with our viewers
some of the actual numbers the cdc says
unvaccinated adults are 68 more times at
risk of dying than fully vaccinated and
boosted adults check these out
hospitalization rates for the
unvaccinated that number shoots up as
high as 90 people for every hundred
thousand so those are the numbers those
are the facts those are the facts and i
just want to point out that when i had a
conversation with nils yesterday he and
i asked him and said you know some are
saying that you're trying to censor joe
rogan he's very clear he believes in the
first amendment he believes that joe
rogan and anybody else has a first
amendment right to say whatever they
want he says he doesn't want his music
his artistry associated with the
platform that would allow him does he
say other artists will follow suit he's
talking he's talking to a lot of artists
we don't have any names yet but we'll
see i mean these musicians are not going
to win this battle right you have a
first amendment right to say what you
want you don't have a first amendment
right to appear on a platform as large
as spotify that's the issue joe rogan is
correct that the medical world gets
stuff wrong but there's a process by
which the medical world corrects itself
and that process is not interviewing
guys on the fringe of the medical world
on your massive platform that's called
irresponsible it's not censorship right
editors are not sensors they're ensuring
quality the other problem too is people
say well just turn it off you don't have
to listen to it the thing is a lot of
people do listen to it and they're
getting false
incorrect information and that's why it
seems so dangerous and it matters huge
reach yeah yeah he just says he's having
a conversation that's what joe rogan
will say but it's a life or death issue
that's why it's in a special category
not an opinion about space or something